depuis plusieurs mois nous avons assisté
à des atermoiements successifs du
gouvernement je ne reviendrai pas sur la
taxe sur les carburants sur l'impôt sur
les sociétés il existe l'exit tax les
charges sur les sur les heures
supplémentaires la la csg et bien
d'autres la liste est très longue et
récemment nous avons eu en effet des
déclarations contradictoires sur la taxe
d'habitation sur l'impôt sur les
successions ou sur les sf
mardi dernier le président la république
a rajouté j'allais dire au catalogue les
80 km heure les réversions donc ma
question est simple pouvez vous éclairer
le scénar ou tenter d'éclairer le sénat
sur la feuille de route en matière de
politique fiscale pour répondre aux
exigences fixées par le président de la
république pour vous répondre en la
parole ecobiz de l'économie et des
finances monsieur bruno le maire de la
parole monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice vais vous rassurer sur notre
feuille de route
notre feuille de route c'est baisser les
impôts baisser d impôt pour les ménages
baisser les impôts pour les entreprises
bc impôts pour les ménages chez la taxe
d'habitation
vous connaissez la conviction sur le
sujet j'estime que cet impôt doit être
totalement supprimée pour l'ensemble des
ménages
ça n'exclut pas que la question soit
posée aux français je vous rappelle la
position qui est la mienne
s'agissant de la fiscalité sur le
capital l'usf le prélèvement forfaitaire
unique
je vous redis aussi ma conviction forte
il faut baisser l'impôt sur le capital
pour que nos entreprises puissent
investir innover créer des emplois et
donc je suis favorable à ce que nous
maintenions la suppression de l'impôt
sur la fortune et le prélèvement
forfaitaire unique mais vous êtes de ce
côté-là de l'hémicycle comme je le pense
dans tout cet hémicycle favorable à la
réindustrialisation de notre pays il n'y
aura pas de reconquête industrielle en
france sans baisser les impôts et les
taxes sur le capital et sans baisser les
impôts de production sur l'ain
ce tri ça fait 20 ans que l'on fait
croire aux français qu'on peut avoir une
industrie forte avec des impôts élevés
et bien le million d'emplois supprimés
dans l'industrie montrent que ce n'est
pas la bonne voie
nous poursuivrons donc la baisse des
impôts sur l'industrie et sur l'ensemble
des entreprises françaises en ramenant
l'impôt sur les sociétés de 33 % à 25 %
en france d'ici 2022
ça n'exclut pas non plus belles âmes des
roches baisser les impôts pour tous les
français baisser les impôts pour
l'économie en france 2 un point minimum
sur cinq ans cela n'empêche pas non plus
d'aller chercher l'argent là où il se
trouve et de mettre en place comme nous
allons le faire
une juge de taxes sur les géants du
numérique qui s'appliquera à compter du
1er janvier 2019 pour que tous les gens
du numérique payant franche le même
montant d'impôt que nos pme et de
petites entreprises
madame de roche jour merci monsieur le
premier ministre monsieur le ministre
vous avez donnez vos propres convictions
mais nous avons beaucoup de déclarations
de vos collègues du gouvernement qui
sont contraires à ce que vous venez de
dire or on a eu vingt mois d'une
politique péremptoire avec aucun écho à
nos propositions
maintenant nous sommes sûr parti pour
quelques mois d'incertitude jusqu'à la
fin du débat mais que de temps perdu et
que n'avez vous écoutez les sénateurs
nous qui sommes au plus près du terrain
et qui connaissons la vraie vie c'est
pas tango permanent déclaratif sont
terriblement anxiogène pour nos
concitoyens que ce soit les chefs
d'entreprise les agriculteurs les
particuliers les classes enfin les
classes moyennes les familles cela
change tout le temps et chacun voit bien
ce qui est donné d'une main repris
doublement voire plus de l'autre côté
donc je terminerai par une formule d'un
économiste pourtant modérées la
politique fiscale du gouvernement ce
n'est plus une usine à gaz mais toute
une zone industrielle
[Applaudissements]